[Music]
you are men and women of Hillsdale
steeped in the best traditions and
principles of our great nation if you
don't lead by example who will today the
liver arts are under attack in Hillsdale
College is the best defense it could
hope for we've read the old books and
engaged in a dialogue which recognizes
that the answers are not easily found
humans scuba diving at sombrero read it
was amazing so this cool to be on my own
and this Explorer be all the fish and
all the colors and explore the caves
that the yields were hiding in was just
a great experience the trip was a really
cool combination of the biblical sites
and being exposed to the geopolitical
situation and Israel
our shotgun team is really great they
are very competitive they born four of
the last five years of division three
national championships
[Music]
[Music]
the college is old it's a wonderful
thing about it it was founded by heroes
and wise people they founded it just
like the United States was founded
according to principles that claim to be
eternal the importance of who replaces
Justice Scalia the principles that they
body will make a huge difference in the
liberties and freedoms that we have in
future there is no higher honor than
aware of the uniform of the United
States and going defend freedom there is
no higher on I love this constitution I
love the rule of law it's a rare special
unbelievably valuable and unique
tradition that we inherited this is
Hillsdale College and you are special
that shining city on a hill may God
bless each of you now and throughout
your lives and may God bless america
you